you
before we go here's one thing you can do
today to live a happier healthier and
more productive life it's part of our
partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcast happier
researchers find many Americans
experience holiday stress don't you know
and with Thanksgiving this week two of
the main stressors our family
get-togethers and avoiding conflict at
the dinner table New York Times
bestselling author Gretchen Rubin is
here and drew Carey from the prices
around yeah okay so how can people
prepare for a difficult relative and how
can they be sure that they themselves
are not the difficult relatives yeah
yeah well one of the things is think
about it in advance we can't change the
difficult relative we can only work on
ourselves so think about where where we
run into problems in the past how can I
act the way I want to behave like if I
know I'm gonna have problems with Uncle
Bob sit at the other end of the table
think about it what happens when Uncle
Bob Bob throws that fire bomb at the
table so one of the things you can say
is just try to make a joke of it there's
absolutely time for like debate but to
say let's agree to disagree and give
everybody something to be thankful for
and then maybe redirect like what's a
great new television show everybody's
watching to try to get the conversation
yeah what's but what have what's been
happening on The Price is Right and what
about managing expectations because part
of the problem is that people go into
thanks even though this year is gonna be
different it's gonna be not right well
one of it research does show that
rituals and traditions help to boost
people's happiness and help with family
cohesion but if you're the one that
wants everything to be perfect kind of
ease up on yourself and say we can the
important thing is that we're getting
together even if everybody's not
behaving perfectly and if you're the one
that's like look why does it matter for
you at 5 or 7 o'clock if it really
matters to someone else try to go along
because for some people those traditions
are very very important like a difficult
okay is it okay to say shut up Uncle Bob
[Laughter]
what's the importance of letting people
reminding people why we are here yeah
the part about gratitude yeah being
thankful it's Thanksgiving give thanks
you can be thankful for you travel you
got to travel you didn't have to travel
you got to cook you didn't have to cook
if you're unclean up duty hey they have
a dishwasher I'm grateful for that fine
gratitude we give Uncle Bob take out the
garbage even at your house I have a
friends giving this year Gretchen Rubin
thinks that does it for us